finally uh i probably enjoyed this a
little bit more than i should here's
a local news report out of troy michigan
about a bunch of grown adults
who lined up all night in frigid
temperatures this is michigan remember
it is december now and they lined up all
night outside of a walmart
for a video game console only to be
severely disappointed when the walmart
actually opened
watch this so the rumor was that walmart
here in troy had the playstation 5. it's
one of the hottest items for this
holiday season well
word got out and about a hundred people
started lining up at about midnight
yes sir look at this how long you guys
how many days you guys tried to get this
playstation for 12 hours
12 hours you've been here yes sir why is
it so important to get one of these
we need them when the doors open a
stampede of people went into the store
led by foddy from troy and people are
wanting to get in
look at this look at this but only to
find out that walmart had no
ps5s that's according to the manager
right body
uh she comes and tells us that they have
none in stock so if we were told that
they're gonna have on the stock monday
and we waited seven hours on the
freezing cold of 28 degrees
why is there zero stock okay
uh that's uh that's good you know what
serves you right
serves your right this is how you decide
to spend your night
waiting in a walmart parking lot for 12
hours how do you not call the walmart
first that's my question
now we were told in the report that a
rumor there was a rumor
they heard from somewhere before you
even
think about getting your tent out and
can't be how do you not just
call them and say hey are you getting
the ps5s in
no but apparently nobody did that they
just i don't know they were driving by
they saw other people waiting
what are you guys waiting for oh we're
we've been waiting for 12 hours for a
ps5 well i guess i will too then
and then they run in and uh there's no
ps5 they have to be escorted out by a
police officer
so many questions arise for me when i
see this
first question is why just why in
general
i i have i have never wanted
a consumer product enough to wait even
an
hour for it i've never seen an hour-long
wait
for anything where i actually said to
myself oh i'm i'll do that
that's worth it if i see and
this is why i won't go to this my wife
tries to get me to go to disney world i
won't go to disney world i won't go to
amusement parks
even like a even like a five-minute wait
you need that needs to really be
justified it has to really really be
worth it
an hour hell no i'm not waiting for a
for
a thing a product especially when i know
that okay i can just order it online
what are you doing
you just order it online you have to
wait a couple more weeks
um so that's that's the first question i
have
and then the second question though
maybe more more pertinent
is is uh this is in michigan
and we're not not only is it like 20
degrees overnight
but very strict with the covid
restrictions there in michigan
you know that's definitely one of those
states where they're telling you no more
than 10 people
don't visit your your grandmother or
thanksgiving and christmas
so you can't get together with your
family over the holiday
um they're shutting down all these you
know all these indoor establishments
yet a hundred people can huddle together
outside of a walmart to buy a
video game console they weren't even
wearing masks did you notice that
normally that wouldn't bother me i don't
care if you wear a mask or not
but no police shut the police only
showed up when walmart called them to
escort the people out of the building
because
i guess they were they were uh they were
disgruntled over the fact that there was
no there's no ps5
that's amazing to me or it's not really
amazing because we're used to this sort
of uh
this sort of hypocrisy by now but it
should be amazing
it's what we've discovered you know it's
the this um
this immunity enjoyed by shoppers at b
big retail outlets continues i guess
if you're shopping at walmart for
consumer products
you're immune just like if you're
marching for racial equity
you're immune you're celebrating joe
biden you're immune
um you're going to the funeral of a of a
of a passed away democrat or someone who
or or someone was shot by police you're
immune
really incredible scientifically maybe
bill nye the science guy can explain the
science behind that because i
i gotta admit i'm pretty stupid i don't
fully understand it myself
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future
content